this is still resonating this is
happening on my whole face for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by currency the album y'all Street
confidential up now out no grabbing if
you don't already head all right you
know how the show works yeah yeah I'm
down and I know some people haven't
cleared this tray and I'm down to throw
my hat in the ring strong words to start
it out
the first wing sriracha
that's like ketchup no big deal right
okay first question
what are the most important things that
master P taught you about being your own
boss
pretty much that in the music business
you control you write your own ticket
you write your own check because you're
the one who's making the music so as
long as you're working you're always
creating opportunities to get paid this
stuff is not like ketchup a little bit
more yeah okay I got I got bite down to
this next one Tapatio out of California
seventy-two percent the heat of a
jalapeno I know you probably get asked
the same weed questions in every
interview but if you don't mind I got
one for you
okay so a lot of celebrities are getting
into the weed game now your pals
Wiz Khalifa soup dog and even that Real
Housewives of New York Bethenny Frankel
she's gonna have like a Skinnygirl
marijuana thing that's couple that's on
the prize well that's cool that's why I
always thought out of all the net never
watch those shows but I think she was
okay
who know you know she was getting
torched so clearly that's what that is
she's getting that like it seems to me
that you wouldn't get into that business
unless you had some interest in it blue
smoke one Bethany I know that you only
smoke papers but have you ever thought
about maybe like the edibles I know
snoop he has a really cool peanut butter
yeah he's got there he's got those kiva
boss those taste good I just I never
really I've haven't I haven't sat down
long enough to feel the effect I just
eaten because they taste good for sure
what um what do you think you would what
do you think you'd sell would you do
like a bon bon line or like what do you
think of cereal just a flat-out like a
STONER
just say can see the motivation and not
going to go anywhere
what would you call it bong Loops
all right this next one is a Yucatec Oh
Caribbean chili habanero a kind of
fruity okay let's go for this disjoint
huh how does the percent I don't know
yet this one didn't really do anything
you see that's a burrito that's the
thing some of these are like tiny oh
they kind of Trojan horse like a little
bit like sometimes that one caught you
though
what's up the question hey when you have
an album out you treat yourself do you
go out and buy yourself something do you
celebrate is there a new car on the
horizon what's the deal yeah I go out
and I buy wings and then douse them in L
you could take Oh nuclear hot sauce
different tribes and different in the
country when they do certain things
right I got you Clara loops and all kind
of [ __ ] so that's what this isn't like
walking across the hot coals because my
hours out right a passenger some [ __ ]
like that yeah do this all the time
alright this next one is High River
hellacious hot sauce new to season two
of hot ones mmm it's like this uh
habanero just look like on a probation
this looks like a barbecue sauce to move
are you gonna oh I thought you're gonna
dumb the high on the I was like Jesus Oh
rice man whoo all right hi River High
River sauces I love when NAR doir
interviews snoop and I love when nard
waar interviews you and so this part of
the interview was kind of inspired by
nard where I have presents her lasers
our show has changed great right it's
pretty good yeah okay yeah it's good so
I have some presents for you they're not
old albums unfortunately but I have
snacks you're like the snack [ __ ] so
no I want to give you some snacks and
you can totally keep these tell me what
you think
cheddar bacon mac and cheese Lay's
potato chips I feel like this is a
stoners delight right as long as you got
a beverage this is good
tell me what you think of these and let
the not let the people know what you got
there got some oh man this dude isn't a
snack Emporium damn these are swingers
this is this is chester Cheetah but
these are cinnamon sugar puffs I don't
know if ever this is like [ __ ]
cinnamon twist from Taco Bell but
Cheetos kind of like my bongos so if the
people that chester Cheetah Ville want
to talk cereal
we can definitely line up on Bono's
because it looks like you guys aren't
afraid to try things with flavors and
ideas there's a [ __ ] cheetah going
down the sled in the snow and send them
a sugar puff so I'm with it limited time
let's make this last forever okay this
is kind of a classic come on animal
crackers there's nothing you can do
about that there's a string that we
named after animal crook is it good
animal cookies there's platinum animal
cookies oh because animal crackers are
just a very good thing I used to bite
all the heads off I think that's what
everybody yeah yeah yeah you its own if
you give them your mutilate them you buy
days off and then you finish them off so
yeah all right how about this ah well I
know people who swear by the devil I
know people who won't shut the [ __ ] up
about Nutella but I have yet to try
because I never understood what it was
is it peanut butter it's like a
chocolate yeah chocolate you're the
chocolate spread like you know like when
your mom would make brownies right and
then you'd get to write so this is kind
of like that it's kind of like that oh
oh [ __ ] okay yeah like frosting frosting
and pretzels we'll give it a go man I
don't know that these these combinations
are these overseas purchasing no no no
no no these are our issues around CVS
downstairs what CVS cause this stuff
looks like like when you're in Amsterdam
or something you like it looks like are
you tipping the one of them stores and
it's the same brand since you familiar
with this
a vision never heard of like this is
like that [ __ ] pain is good Louisiana
style Louisiana so you have to my own
heart with it we try to try it 218 hot
sauce just do it looks like this sauce
is awfully painful pain is good and this
is menials this medium so let's go for
that with micro [ __ ] Smurfs and a small
batch big flavor they have a big chunk
of it right here to swim yes maybe be
careful mm-hmm [ __ ] love it down to
I'm gonna go right then you dive in Pro
broker but I had a question you know
you're from one of the best food cities
in the world give you he moves along as
man that's really why I know people from
all is gonna be on my ass about this
because just have some are these hot
sauces on they are taking me through the
ringer but oh hey you know I always
think that you could do a diners
drive-ins and dives
no lowrider is a show so this show take
me through New Orleans like give me
something off menu give me something oh
well honestly if you go to uh I can tell
you the place give me a you go to a
magnolia grill and get that chicken and
waffles yeah and that's not on the menu
that's not on the menu and that's
because I had to go in there and suggest
to them I did they thought I made up the
combination they never heard of my and
for a while for like two weeks I just
let them run with that they're like whoa
courtesy came in here just came up with
this recipe
they're just telling her about you and
we got the special colors and checkers
and waffles chicken and waffles or the
say players get crazy so they was gonna
crazy brown I had AI winning that one
down like Helia okay okay I didn't make
the [ __ ] up y'all like come on thought
y'all knew that chicken waffles existed
but it's still not on the menu but if
you're going in you say my name they'll
bring you the plate
hammer i revoke um this is a so it's
spicy but here's the real good blood
orange there's that's the thing it's got
blood oranges garlic um some apple
actually and this one apple is a private
show so I think at the end they undercut
it just a little to where there's cool
there before the flavor I don't know
what Muruga is
our scorpion pepper so okay but squirt
scorpion but you know what they chop it
up they blended in it's not like [ __ ]
eating a scorpion pepper hole oh [ __ ]
alright let's go for you have your hair
- scorpion pepper I had I've had way
hotter than scorpion peppers I've had a
Carolina Reaper that's the hottest
pepper in the entire world is there
video footage you do stuff dude I'm
gonna hit no yeah I want to see I want
to see this I want to show you I wanna
see I'll show you all right what's the
best TV show in 2015 to watch ball high
you got to take a bite you're not
getting one by me man Rick and Morty
Rick a morning on Adult Swim is the best
to watch what I because it's playful
enough like one of those in the daytime
a DOS I mean Cartoon Network shows like
are like Teen Titans go or something
like that but [ __ ] but it's like awfully
vulgar to kind of runt you too but it's
intelligent but if you pay attention to
movies like Back to the Future and [ __ ]
and you watch them for the science
involved in them too and that that that
did something to you the natural wood
tool which one is this
so this distal one this is the first
time it actually really reduces that
cartons happening right now here that
soccer quarter didn't happen so this
next one we got 100% pain which as the
name would suggest is not a fun one this
one to me is the second worst with you
saying it you don't think this wasn't
you don't think this was a formidable
opponent I've never met never met a wing
that I couldn't handle you know what I
mean um this is still resonating this is
happening on my whole face right this is
bad that's gonna let me ask you this you
smoked today yeah yeah right so I think
that when you smoke hot food becomes
hotter like I think your top rating with
like I've got a stack
over here because if I smoke and I go to
Chipotle I won't even get the peppers
and those are julienne peppers you know
what I've been diggin it probably does
something and time smoke is just sitting
in here and it's probably like opening
up pores or something you know I don't
know I feel [ __ ] Oh like but they say
that you get like a narcotic like high
if you eat hot sauce like what you don't
know when I'm not high so you might but
we might you might catch it no no get
your way all right there's cool man
okay so this one's pain 100% hot sauce
two and a half times hotter than a
jalapeno it was like the dumbest show
ever
ah my face hurts legit all right host
this 100% pain no there's a chunk of
this [ __ ] right there
yeah actually out of way I'm not gonna
do that yeah um that move veteran says
this one brutal which one's brutal I'll
tell you ever hang wrap what's the
poison it down on him damn imma take
like chicken the moon ya know it's just
kind of ruins the wing I don't know why
they do that oh come on come on come on
man hmm all right so I know you're a
lowrider guy but you also say things
like you could learn Italian to my drive
right yeah so I wonder if there's a
difference between is you know grabbing
the keys in the morning is it just like
putting on a sweatshirt
or is there a difference between Chevy
lowrider day yeah you today it depends
Laurie day I'm liable I'm more inclined
to wear a Ralph Lauren a collared shirt
maybe not maybe out done where the Cuban
and stuff to drive the Ferrari cuz I'm
like I'm it's already doing with this
door flashing up we're not when I Drive
the lowriders remember music I'm gonna
listen to and I know how I feel and no
one I look in the mirror I'm gonna
see myself looking my coolest so I'm
going to have my chain official do you
have any advice for talking your way out
of tickets because I'm sure that you've
had your fair share
driving around try some of this hundred
percent pain and then start talking and
you're gonna be so fast with words that
you're probably just going to mesmerize
them and weave a tapestry of lies around
the capsule fastes he's going to let you
go this is the bombs beyond insanity
alright alright but we're all ready to
eat and uh your dog guy you're sweating
a little bit in the face yeah how far
they can't let go I'm wearing the big
jacket in the knit cap - how far you can
go before you put my eyes water
Khaled very pathetic effort three Daniel
okay alright so your dog plays a
prominent role on your Instagram I want
to show you some rap dogs some of them
you probably already know and I just
want you to react to what Noah I want
you to say if you got any stories about
it I want you to say if you want to
adopt them I wanted to say if maybe they
don't have it first we got push it to
you CJ tell me about CJ this dog has
probably got countless bags of cocaine
lined in this bag is probably like
smuggling coke to from Bolivia with this
dog so he's probably with that that dog
is a dad already knows that bag is the
run [ __ ] America's most horny about
your boy riff Raff's Jodie husky oh [ __ ]
there was a dog like this they chased me
to school every day we named him Jack
the wolf I believe he was a matter
business our Burien or maybe an Alaskan
Malamute or something but we ran from
him all the time this guy doesn't say
rap dog but he does say riff raff stones
right riff raff is my homie and riff
raff was on pilot talk three you look at
this dog that dog says riff raff here's
your friend Wiz Khalifa's Vincent you
know Vincent yeah [ __ ] though I gave
where's Vincent really yeah I guess
that's a revelation I gave this guy the
Wiz this is a is from SD bullies all my
dogs are from SD
we got a real good relationship with
those guys and when Vincent's litter
came out I picked him out of the pack
and I'm like yo that guy there like for
you like no no no I'm gonna give him to
my brother you know saying and mainly
because he had just had bash and I'm
like y'all should all just come up
together right now you know so it's
working and you see them chillin in the
lowrider with a bandana so I don't know
like he's complaining about his life so
you know I did that for you man enjoyed
it
all right next one Mad Dog 357 this was
actually our hottest sauce last season
now it's our second hottest walk what's
up what video games you got on the oh
[ __ ] what what video games do have on
the tour bus
maxie on the UH on my computer I got the
the [ __ ] 2d Grand Theft Auto like the
og one you're on Grand Theft Auto you're
on the soundtrack yeah yeah yeah but
talk about the whole way uh no other
games on the bus man [ __ ] diamond
mines you play video games I got do but
they all at home I don't bring anything
on the bus cuz I don't want anything to
get scratched up we had gunplay in here
did he do this
yeah he got all the way through he
probably dropped the [ __ ] yeah he was
better than me all right
but he was saying that he does it all
with like the headset and [ __ ] do you
get like that into it are you barking at
14 year old kids and one oh my god oh ho
mean it does I got a homie that gets
barked at by 14 year olds like to the
point where I've told him that maybe I
should reach out to those kids parents
and let them know how to talk no gunplay
told that story too but he talked about
it's basically rolling up what was this
one who's this this is mad dog 357
seventy one point four times hotter than
a jalapeno all right last one oh no not
for me cuz
I didn't eat the Mandar when you go is
tap out
yeah yeah just hurry up start asking
this question right now I might have to
write it yeah think of what is hurting
to talk
I might just write things yeah it's
texted to me
mm-hmm all right this 357 Maddog this
has also abolutely 357,000 on this
Scoville chart exactly way hotter than
that but seventy one point four times
hotter than a jalapeno nobody's gonna be
mad at you
cool all right let's go okay last one
it's tradition to dab well you don't
have to if you don't want to but no one
but I will cuz I got I got a reputation
relax a little
oh you [ __ ] all right cheers buddy you
made it
kaylynn [ __ ] I'm of this we talk
a lot about not wanting to play industry
games mmm
whenever you say industry games and
never know you're talking about what do
you mean by industry games [ __ ] have
some challenges and with that said I'm
gonna go man Canal Street confidential
go pick it up they have 30 seconds this
is all yours
Canal Street confidential [ __ ] pick
it up I don't think I can utilize the 30
seconds because I'm [ __ ] sweating so
uh futures on their tide dollar signs on
their little wings on their August
Alsina zone their K camps on their beans
on their I'm gonna raise that man just
pick it up man smoked waffle cone the
boy P I'm out
you